yes or no and welcome to this video
which is a new part of this middle game
strategy series where I solve a couple
of maybe two yeah we would see what
happens and yeah strategically focused
positions and see what happens I'm going
to talk you through the thought process
and we are going to put some lines on
the board during my thing to make it a
little bit turn yet that is easy to
follow so I'm going to use the GM
prepositional playbook again and it's
going to randomly generate a number
all right sunny behind 134 last time now
have 133 you see that yeah yeah 130 good
so I have to set this up so this 133
yeah let's not edit I know I'm going to
MJ the board 133 I should have checked
about know the position I actually do
know the position if once you garland
Bono's is 1994 I know the position so
okay after doing you generate 17c that's
empty
probably will believe me anyway but I'm
going to do it yeah and once you
garnered bonus is 1994 look it up it's a
cool game okay yeah that can happen I
know quite a bunch of positions so
number 70
no no I don't know that position so
black to play an orientation is black
yes'm
it's important and maybe I should to
just set it up it's easier to have this
orientation so um let's set that up I
could actually pause the video what I do
that yeah that's not really exciting
base I move for improvement but I want
to make it authentic and that I don't
that you don't think I'm proof select
stuff and so on but just that you know
like kickin up like a 1g8 Bishop here
yes we I at least it's pretty easy to
identify that we had a denied or
Sicilian was in play here if you can see
pretty quickly come on
rooks Queen White Queen on a for so I
think this is the position
[Music]
yeah but it is black to play and we
should look at it from black and I have
to get have it off yeah and it's not
exercise 133 but exercise 70 and so yeah
I mean you probably might as well just
fast forward yes next time
okay so this is the tradition it's black
to play in proper sort of sweet like a
leukemia yeah back in the day where
kayaking still played the night o of
regularly instead of the Bullen okay so
it's do we have equal material opposite
sides castles and our knight on f6 is
attacked
the most obvious move would be just to
move the night probably you have to move
it I mean I don't see a technical idea
27 maybe 27 but that would be an
alternative to moving the light yeah but
I don't know if that is any good anyway
but just saying that could be something
else than the night move is there any
other candidate no not really I cannot
take something also cannot threaten made
no no so I probably have to move the
night or play this Queen d7 move into
the positional play exercise sometimes
this helps yeah it a bit they had to
know that there should be some some some
kind of strategic um part of this that
it's not just a purely a pure
calculation thing yeah so what's going
on here yeah I think from a strategic
point of view I probably with black I
probably don't want you don't want to
play an ending them against the bishops
and then open board a six is probably
weak a bit weak yeah in an ending at
least the middle game not so much but in
an ending the middle game it's always a
question or two take a six with a key
one c1 so yeah the most natural move
would be would be Knight to d7 but you
I feel I don't quite get it I mean 2 H 5
H 5 looks really a really strange and
3/8 I mean 97 looks extremely obvious it
says something entirely different
this is made idea of course on c2 what I
don't really get get to distract the
Queen
- 97 caliber what else or dwell me
something in totally like do I miss a
candidate
I mean 95 blunders the thing and 98 I
really don't see the point
one thing about Knight h5 could be to
put it on f4 and initiate this this
trade when you give get the Bishop only
three of it 9 h5 just Bishop d3 and
white then when maybe then D fire and
let h5 still look strange is 97 what is
this is there anything anything great
against 97 there is potentially Bishop
h3 and then I would have to claim the
aid which will also doesn't look great
hmm
okay Duane's
can move all together I don't I don't
see it I don't really see anything else
than the nine moves maybe I'm too long
here I mean sticking too long with this
question when this candidate moves but
it's something that I think is really
important to not calculate deeply I mean
if you can that's good but I think it's
it's important to make sure that you
don't miss anything on the first one or
to move something possibility that's
really fundamental so what you have to
move the knight so 9 h5 looks wrong I
mean it's also known like in this
position type of if you get to f4 and
white takes it and
takes to the cleaner air for and then
put submission 23 that is reasonably
safe even though even though there might
be called to play against between that
is actually a point maybe I get
counterplay by means of but playing
against will be to pawn and 9h 5
therefore isn't bad 97 that I really
dislike I mean it looks extremely
passive even even a move like Bishop d3
might be good intending we should be 4
and because if I go like 97 I mean I
promise to move it tickets yeah yeah
even even this yeah sorry I'm kind of
used to not removing the pieces because
it's my typical mode also in Lesson such
as I move it so that things get
calculated for real like it isn't a
normal game like here you can maybe put
this here and this is a pretty
dominating situation you can go this is
a move now this is actually a very
sensible move because there is this this
idea ah this is actually an important
resource even if this is played 95 is
that something takes we should text you
find it that's probably not enough
that's definite give the exchange but we
should be 395 is actually a point
so this is probably the critical move
and now 95 and white can take because
this is just ultimately in exchange and
I don't think you have enough that means
that I need to play this which is really
really really passive even even though
hey I mean I don't see how I'm losing
immediately not be signal Knight b6 or a
screen a fiver that's it's really
successful ocean even this is a good
more strategically put the Queen in the
middle of the board I don't know
Kim 97's really passive maybe maybe I
have to do that you have this light h5
stuff and then put it on a forward right
chef forward will basically force them
to take on a form then we go to opposite
colored Bishop scenario so this is what
I'm talking about and now maybe this
intending to play Queen to d7 if he
attacks this just dropping I'm just
giving away the pawn like this like and
trying to play against this or in this
particular case this is also move
threatening here and here if I get this
pawn and put the bishop on e6 then I'm
actually probably better we be sure the
so strong or net weakened King side yeah
I have to go Knight h5 in this pollution
or is there something else entirely a
move like 98 that that initially looks
bad is that maybe not so bad and you
know this this might be not that
terrible and you can actually imagine
that black is going to play the Queen to
b7 Knight to c7 and then play d5 hmm
that is that's actually quite true
let's um let's not totally discard that
even though it looks bad it's not it's
not so clear how wide is going to keep
keep it with control now maybe even this
move
if white tries this 55 and this doesn't
look bad okay I think 97 is too passive
98 is maybe better than it looks even
though you can just say okay well what
is just going going for the kill here
right this this yeah well let that is
attacked it is attacked I don't know I
wanted to actually set an alarm clock to
not look at this for too long I don't
really have a solution right this is not
even with this this kind of scenario and
sometimes it's sometimes tough to say if
they go the bishop I played with Bishop
h3 I think this is usually the better
choice for Bishop reform let's just say
I do this is this I don't know each form
on h3 and then put the bishop yeah edge
would be better for white and Isis this
remains passive even though I can go g6
be sure if I hit
my gut feeling says Knight h5 to have 94
and potentially you know here you can
maybe play this this this and claim that
the bishop on g7 will allow you to
always defend that is maybe true my gut
feeling is 9h five and ninety seven I
think let me do that make me 997 I feel
that looks just looks passive it looks
passive maybe I'm not right there with
my expensive to me my gut feeling is not
h5 probably I'm I am completely off so
I'm going to going to check it it's not
also not that I'm not super familiar
with those structures but okay and I
completely missed the first move I look
to a bit but I didn't spot the rule yeah
I had this I had this feeling I didn't
see it the solution is this move okay
yeah save safely attach to xkx clams
yeah once you see that they kind of
appreciated yeah that threatens route
before we do may I didn't see it I just
didn't see the idea
this is the thing this is called
positional play this book without
position Allah said move I mean you need
to technical solution because probably
the specific like any of my solutions
but yeah okay so we should be free the
ship t3 air can also switch that on my
black is already better according to the
engine Bishop d3 was the game after
which 97 Queen 4 g6 and neck was clearly
better
yes probably probably difficult to to
even keep everything together we should
be 64 supposed to be better which is not
exactly intuitive and then trying to try
to make a draw here
okay Yahoo p8 is strong and you know
I've looked for a while yeah so do I
have other candidate news but so I
didn't I did not see that move not at
all it's not so difficult once you
actually have the presence of my to look
for most other than night news and I did
but I still didn't didn't see this one
well anyway it's a good position to get
exercise and it is as as we mentioned
and probably not exactly easy so I'm
going to do a second position and we
have 98 Michigan I know that position
again kayaking kayaking trip on your Chi
[Music]
eight black law kayaking is white so
what looks again that looks again like
in I do or for very likely and I love my
cognac she is an idol player plane it is
a typical night off structure I mean it
could also be some psycho for so much I
don't think so okay we have a king and
here's also King Queen here should be a
night here and this is almost right it
is right here okay like to play like
no I didn't see it
okay I promise I didn't see it okay um
so would just like to claim make sure
that is when it correct them
yeah so white is looking at that beehive
porn there's some likelihood that the
last move was a four I mean my initial
impression of this position is that
black should be fine because white does
not have any sufficient a grip on d5 and
a four I mean it doesn't feel extremely
dangerous if I just play like first
impression queen c6 or Queen d7 takes on
behind gay eight Queen aids and that
that is not really a problem one thing I
just spotted though is let's say Queen
d7 8xb v 8x b5 okay
Queen a8 Queen B five Queen takes e4
that's 56 Brooke d6 Queen eight mate but
move d6 I have the check as well yeah so
just to show what I meant what I meant
I just just sometimes you want to look
at this like strategic leave it then you
see a line and you immediately look at
it yeah here there's a mate only hm
there's something is the true word
didn't miss h6 awesome yeah maybe this
doesn't work because of the check weight
sleep sometimes you just have those
flashes on line that means there is no
immediate technical issue
what else most natural move is probably
d5 yam pushing this if he takes on b5 is
there something something going on in
some cases you can also just take on a
fire and then play Queen b7 and and d5
but okay let's do a more general
approach let's look at weaknesses I have
been fine
I mean b5 is something to take into
account for sure d6 I've got covered but
it is a backward Paul it's not really
all that week but after have to watch
out why it doesn't have it why can't the
slide we both have sliding big
backgrounds and but other than that
white white pieces you know they are not
really good the bishop one in three
years kind of an on piece looks into
thin out and the nine of every is also
not great all Knights cannot go to defy
for example really difficult to imagine
so how do we play it really doesn't look
like very critical to me if I take on
these four chicks I mean like this is
this there is this thing so I don't
think this makes all that much sense
this is kind of the system most normal
looking move it covers this and we're
preparing d5 I would somehow really like
to somehow exploit this fork distance if
I has a fork but I don't see how those
pieces look clumsy but really not
obvious how to do it this is some a twin
line to Queen d7 this actually threatens
him so maybe this is actually more less
force here here
I mean this is okay right I have this
and I easily cover all that I mean white
black is not reverse IAM do I miss
anything here I mean I would just
probably play Queen 66 or queen bee 7
anything else entirely I mean we off we
have to check the pieces and wait just
thinking if a is a 5 an idea for what a
5 and then like Bishop should be 6
it is a bit irritating if I do this I
just paid the five fare come on
[Music]
I don't see any problem running is there
something else like that I've totally
failed to miss in terms of a wide idea
what can watch you take here and try to
make this work
I had super slow I mean I'm ready 45 so
when this candidate move anything else
there don't see
however I think you just come six yeah
maybe I'm just too unsophisticated if
you see the big point okay nineteen
position 96 and probably there will be
something amazing now that yes look at
see better up and 398 ok click 26 is
wrong
[Music]
I mean I saw the more food I didn't okay
let's see let's see
and so Quincy six is what I wanted to do
it is to move that nefeli actually plate
I have ended yeah and he all that said
this is wrong let us just say CY so
exactly this line and then he says 91
with 92 to come and white is obviously
better yeah well really maybe maybe
when I saw the idea then I asked him if
i go di cannot really play d5 is the
thing you know then
[Music]
well that is probably an issue even
though engine just placed e4 384 also
doesn't seem like nothing much all got
caused an obvious positional advantage
that maybe I mean I understand
completely understand this point because
it's is definitely annoying you know
that the engine is not a super convinced
just create for yeah this is making you
kayaking by the way also didn't
understand the deep red h4 here and then
nothing much happened I know what you
tend to find watch the Sun all that says
yeah okay so in fact in this is what
should be played and now TX TX Queen c6
Queen c6
what is notice again now all that gives
Quincy tool the computer wants to play
okay f5 and blacks position is crap
which looks pretty obvious actually why
would white why should white play this
move that doesn't make any sense and
then I go d5
yeah great fire obviously it's strange
right like it just cannot play this move
this is not convincing sorry it's not
convincing this is not necessarily any
better d5 is given by the engine here
which is extremely direct
if that wins so if white cannot take 186
and then black is fine yeah
and this is the most convincing
frequently and I understand that my
indeed somewhat superficial groove here
that this is a bit worrisome I
understand that 91 you know the engine
still wants to do this you should
suffice
yeah what we had to assume
yeah this is some negging ash through
the is an image so the best is actually
not the book line I mean this is
actually pretty clearly not good
instead d5s what should be played which
is sane it's easy with the computer of
course and the book is a couple of years
old and all they checked things with
engines but it's some and here I'm
reasonably sure that the computer is
perfectly correct here because it's open
disposition and there's no you sometimes
have the engine same problems with
fortresses or specific endgame types
here probably it sees some complete
liquidation into nothingness so hmm that
was little difficult yeah the first two
exercises and the video last video a lot
more accommodating it better be but it's
interesting and to explore very
difficult stuff as I always say those
books are great but you need to have a
high tolerance level for failure fear or
failure okay guys